yeah so
it's I guess basically everyone I know
who did a non-medical degree went down
the either Investment Banking or
management consulting route and actually
a lot of people I know who do have
medical degrees are now trying to go
down those routes because they're like
oh this is my exit strategy for medicine
they do medicine for a bit they realize
they don't like it and then they're
seeing Oh there's a lot of money over
there there's a lot of money with those
people with their fancy suits and and
stuff um what was Investment Banking
like for you Investment Bank imagine I I
have no idea what investment because I
actually don't really know what an
investment Bank I didn't know what it
was either like I was getting this job I
was like I got to go buy a book about
what is what is Investment Banking and
um you know I was like do I work at a
bank so basically you're supporting
people like at my level like four tiers
down from the person actually doing the
the job I'm like making spreadsheets
okay and the whole idea was an
investment Bank works with companies and
either helps them go public or acquire
companies or get Acquired and kind of
strategic uh Financial transactions like
that so my job was like let's go some
company wants to get acquired they want
to or some company someone wants to go
buy a company in a space and they're
like what should we pay for this company
let's go look at all the private
transactions that have happened in the
space and let's try to get an idea of
what the valuations were relative to
their revenues or relative to their
profit and what are all the public
companies in the space valued at on
these metrics let's come up with an idea
of what's a fair price at the end of the
day you're really just trying to come up
with a way to justify the price that you
agreed on cuz a negotiation so it seemed
like a little bit of show but sometimes
it's literally like we actually need to
do the show to send to our shareholders
so that we show that we did diligence y
um but at my level it was like Hey I'm
going to go home why don't you make this
spreadsheet till 4 in the morning I'll
be back at 8: tomorrow I hope you're
back and I remember a week went by where
I went home and my girlfriend at the
time was asleep and I left before she
woke up and I was like this is horrible
like I don't I've not even seen the
person I live with awake um and I was
like I think I got to take this other
job which was a manic consulting job um
which wasn't that different except
you're making PowerPoints thans yeah
okay so so you were in investment
banking for a few months before
realizing that it wasn't for you yeah it
was so I did the internship at the end
of The Internship they offered me the
full-time job and I was like okay I'll
take the full-time job uh because I was
like oh I need to pay rent so I took the
full-time job up until this management
consulting thing started and I was like
Hey I've actually I'm I'm going to leave
I'm going to take this other thing and
they were kind of like okay like they
weren't upset I kind of was in this
weird spot where they didn't offer me
like they kind of said stay on as a
full-time intern instead of here's a
full-time offer where you're going to
get a bonus and you're G to get all this
stuff they were kind of like well we
want to keep you so as soon as there's
an opening we'll give you a real job
until then you can be a full-time intern
we're going to pay you a little bit more
but it wasn't clear that I had a
full-time job it was kind of a weird
spot and so when the consulting job was
ready to start I was like thank you this
is a great experience I learned a lot
let's see what that's like nice okay so
we you've done your stint in in
Investment Banking um did that teach you
anything other than the fact that you
didn't like Investment Banking I mean I
think you just learn how to grind
through anything you know I I think
there are some jobs where especially now
I meet people are like oh you know I'm
just kind of cruising having fun I'm
living in a van like this was you are
working sometimes 22 hours in a day uh
and you just have to like grind through
things and you're working with very very
smart people even just the interview
process like if never even took the jobs
having to go through these interview
processes where they're asking you to do
these complicated case studies and like
one time it was with a team and so I was
interviewing with other people who were
interviewing together working on a
project and then asked to give feedback
on the people I was interviewing with so
I think I just learned a lot being
surrounded by really smart people and
that was fun but at the end of the day I
think the problem I had with both of
those jobs was that it was very
hierarchical it was like there was a
moment in management consulting where we
were trying to close a deal as a firm
with a you know like a Fortune 500
company and I obviously wasn't the one
selling the deal that was like the
managing director and I was this
low-level you know first year but a
friend of mine happened to have the CEO
of that company was his stepmom and I
was going to hang out at his birthday
party and she was there and I remember
asking the managing director I was like
hey I'm actually going to go to the co
of this company that we want to win
business from I'm going to be at her
house this weekend do you want me to
talk to her about this and he's like no
that's not your job and I'm like I know
that's not my job but it seems like
there probably could at least be a
conversation worth having here and it
was like no that's not your job and I
was just like it feels and maybe I was
too full of myself but it felt a little
irresponsible for the company to not
entertain whether it was good idea um so
it just didn't seem right and then at
the end of the day everything in my kind
of Life trajectory changed when I went
to this event called startup weekend
which was a guy in Boulder started this
thing where he got a bunch of people
together Engineers designers product
people just business people for a
weekend and you all broke into groups
and built companies and I drove up to
Boston from New York City and we built
this company it was silly it was called
desk happy it was a Windows app that
every like some random number of time
like 45 to 90 minutes it would pop up a
thing and it would give you an exercise
like a five minute exercise like stretch
or you know you know that thing where
like the Apple watch will buzz and tell
you to do something it was that for
Windows but like a decade ago and I was
like oh my God we built a company in a
week
nobody downloaded the app like it never
went anywhere but I was like I want to
do this like this is amazing and
everyone's like well you should probably
live in San Francisco like everyone in
San Francisco is building tech companies
and I was like I will do that so I
immediately put in a request I said hey
could I move to San Francisco I'd really
like to work in the San Francisco office
they said sure I was like wow that was
so easy and then like a week into
working in San Francisco I got this call
to go to a meeting with a guy I'd never
met and I was like wow this senior
person wants to meet with me this is
cool and he was like you're fired oh
this was the management consulting thing
yeah yeah so it was 2008 middle of the
financial crisis I had thought you know
they kind of were like oh you're this
person that just transferred offices
you've got nothing on your plate you're
a great person to let go so I was
fortunately uh show you know given an
opportunity to go do something else
which I think at the time I was kind of
disappointed but in the long run I think
it it was a huge impact because it
forced me to go find something else to
do hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye